[Music]
so it's my pleasure to introduce Daniel
MacArthur who is from just down the
street and has been instrumental in
creating a extremely valuable resource
that based on the title of his talk I
think he's going to tell us about and
probably how it's changing the world so
great Thank You Jennifer and thanks for
the opportunity to be here today it's a
great pleasure to be here of course
so Jennifer mentioned I work just to
just down the road of the bird Institute
I have a lab that also spends a fair bit
of time over at Mass General Hospital we
have two focuses one is on rare disease
diagnosis which you've heard a lot about
and I'm not going to talk about today
and the second as Jennifer mentioned is
thinking about ways in which we can
build up very large collections of
genetic variation from the general
population primarily with the focus of
using these as reference databases to
understand what variants do and which
ones are most important for causation of
rare disease and and I think I wanted to
start with generally framing a sense of
why I'm so excited about human genetics
as we stand right now I think it's
actually you know the most exciting
field that's that's going on at the
moment it's the most exciting time to be
working in human genetics and that's
because it provides Human Genetics
provides to the way of moving back and
forth between two very different and
powerful kinds of information so we're
becoming increasingly good as you've
heard from other speakers today at
layering information across the genome
so here in this random random screen
shot from the UCSC genome browser we
have some chunk of the genome and for
each base in the human genome we have
information about about whether that's
present in a gene or not if if so where
that gene is actually expressed within a
non-coding region whether that is also a
regulatory region that may play some
role in regulating gene expression and
this information is increasing thanks to
information like encode and epigenomics
roadmap and gtex and other resources and
then another type of information that we
as a as the broader biomedical community
have become very good at collecting is
information about human phenotypes we
now have millions of people around the
world who have been collected in large
often national scale bio banks and these
people have a whole variety of different
bits of information collected about them
and these can range from information
about particular diseases they've been
diagnosed where may be stored in a more
or less well formatted fashion it's all
sort of the electronic medical record
data prescription registers quantitative
trait data and questionnaires and then
and then a in many cases a whole bunch
of
interesting and rich biological or
functional genomic data like
transcriptomic so metabolomics they can
give us some insight into the biology of
those individuals and human genetics is
cool in part because it provides us with
the way of moving back and forth between
these two kinds of information so the
traditional for genetics way of doing
human genetics is that we would collect
people on the basis of phenotype so do
something like what Gil just talked
about identify sort of families who have
some interesting and very rare disease
group those people and then see what
pieces of DNA they have in common that
is what variation they have in common
and used that to zoom in on particular
genes that may underlie their disease
this has been an incredibly productive
approach we now know more than 4,000
genes associated with Mendelian diseases
and many thousands of regions in the
genome that are associated with common
complex disorders like type 2 diabetes
for instance but as we start to build up
these big bio banks and we start to
sequence that is do DNA sequencing on
more of the people in those bio banks it
becomes feasible to start thinking about
moving in the opposite direction as well
that is to find people and group them on
the basis of their genotype so find for
instance all the people who have
particular disruptive mutations in a
particular gene group them on that basis
and then look to see what they have in
common in terms of their traits this is
what we would call reverse genetics it's
a very common approach to doing things
in model organisms where we can actually
genetically engineer particular mice to
lack a specific gene for instance and
then see what happens to them when we
knock that gene out now of course in
humans we can't do genetic engineering
but what we can do is take advantage of
the enormous amount of genetic variation
that exists in the general population
and the amount of variation that exists
is genuinely staggering if you we can
you can calculate actually relatively
easily based on what we know about the
distribution of mutation rates across
the genome and how many people exist
that given that effectively any given
single nucleotide substitution that is a
particular position in the genome a
change into an A or a C or a G almost
certainly exists out there in the among
the seven billion people that exist in a
population so means humanity in effect
represents an enormous natural
experiment where we have tried certainly
not the complete space of human genomic
sequence but perturbations across many
different regions of the genome and all
we need to do to understand exactly what
effect each of those perturbations have
is sequence the genomes of all seven
billion people on the face of the planet
hook those into a big electronic medical
record system that allows us to go back
in
we contact people based on that
information and then and then
systematically collect for instance all
the Knockouts in a particular gene and
see what they have in common now we are
not as you guys know anywhere close to
being able to sequence seven billion
genomes yet although that will happen
eventually but what we can do is to
start to accumulate information that has
been collected across now well over two
million people who had either their
whole genome sequence or in many cases
their exomes that is a particular
technology that allows us to look just
at the protein coding bits of the genome
so this two million number is a lower
sort of ballpark estimate the these two
million people have been sequenced
through a whole host of different
academic and commercial ventures and
they've been generated in this
information has been generated in sites
around the world collected for a whole
variety of different projects but just
to give you an idea about how fast that
information is growing curves like this
I'm sure had been presented earlier
today but this is information just from
one place the Broad Institute again a
couple of blocks down the road you can
see here the growth in the number of
genomes that have been sequenced from
2009 to 2016 as informations about I
guess about eight months ten months out
of date over here we have the number of
exome sequenced and the two bits of
information you should be taken from
these curves is firstly the number at
the top which tells us we had at the end
of last year sequenced about 70,000
genomes and over a quarter of a million
human exomes the staggering amount of
data but also the shape of this curve in
2016 we sequenced more genomes than in
all years previously combined and so the
trajectory at which we are generating
these data is truly staggering now
ideally what we want to do is to take
all these two million sequence
individuals and house them all together
in one big unified biobank that would
allow us to link between genotype and
phenotype but this turns out to be very
difficult for all sorts of reasons
there's mundane obstacles associated
with moving data from one place to
another
it turns out because these samples have
been collected over many decades I've
been well before they were sequenced the
consent that they were can consented
under is often inadequate to justify
very large-scale data sharing and in
fact a lot of my life is dealing with
inadequate consent and data use
permissions there are objections to data
sharing so in just much of this data has
been generated in an industry setting
and that is often regarded as a trade
secret you guys I'm sure will be shocked
to learn there are even some academics
that are not fully on board with the
idea of sharing data so this computer
and then a final problem that we face is
the fact that different centers who
generate this data tend to process and
perform variant calling across that data
in idiosyncratic ways so if we were to
just take the outputs of all of each of
these different centers and try to merge
together this matrix of two million sets
of genotypes we would end up with a
variant call set that was dominated by
technical differences between centers as
opposed to interesting biological
differences between people which of
course is not useful
so to resolve at least some of these
problems we have been working I guess
for about the last four years on
building up large reference databases of
human variation leveraging the the
expertise and the data that exists of
the bird so when we started this
exercise back in 2012 there were two
large public datasets of human variation
we have the thousand genomes project
which contained about two and a half
thousand low coverage whole human
genomes from a variety of different
populations it's a fantastic project we
also have the NHLBI exome sequencing
project which are generated exome
sequencing from about six and a half
thousand individuals of European or
African American descent and so they cut
a very long story short we began with
these we began analyzing rare disease
patients using these resources and
rapidly found that they were too small
and in many cases too old to be good
comparison data set for our rare disease
patients so we built over a relatively
painful 18-month period our first large
core set of human exomes this is called
the exome aggregation consortium or
exact data set that was released back in
2014 and that contained information from
just over 60,000 human exomes and then
almost to the day two years later in
October last year we released an updated
version of X ACK this is now called the
genome aggregation database or nomad
because we like slightly curious and
idiosyncratic recapitalized names and
this now contains about twice the number
of human exomes and for the first time
in nomads we've also included a whole
collection of human genomes so providing
information about the distribution of
variation across the non-coding that is
the non-protein coding bits of the
genome so it's important to note that
the we did not sequence these samples
these data all come from various studies
and I'll list the pis and and where
these samples come from in a minute from
many different studies we aggregate that
data and we put it through the same
processing pipeline and then we do
variant what we call what's called joint
variant calling
all samples simultaneously or or less
and that allows us to get a harmonized
call set across these large numbers of
samples and this is a testament to the
engineering and scaling work that's been
done at the bird Institute so this is a
brief summary of the pipeline I'm not
going to go through the details about
how our variant calling pipeline works I
don't think it's hugely relevant for
this audience I guess it is worth
emphasizing on this slide we start with
raw raw data we go through a individual
sample variant genotyping variant
calling approach we then do joint
genotyping across large numbers of
samples there's a variant recalibration
approach and then we have this final
call so this very big variant call file
or VCF file that stores all the data
across these samples so the thing I did
want to mention though is that this is a
lot of data so the raw data that's gone
into this project over the exomes data
which is on the left hand side and the
genome data on the right hand side is
about three petabytes of raw sequence
data that condenses down to about 40 a
40 terabytes variant call file which is
which is actually still a staggeringly
large file that we have to work with
many people were involved in generating
and analyzing these data and I wanted to
particularly call out the broad data
Sciences platform for building the tools
that allowed us to call variants of this
scale but also incredibly importantly a
tool a toolkit called the Hale
system which was built at the Broad
Institute I don't know Alex here in the
room is a representative of the Hale
team and Hale was absolutely critical on
being able to go from this 40 terabyte
DCF and actually do important things
with it like quality control and assess
the variants and release data in a
useful way to the public and a huge
thanks to all the members of the team
who contributed to this as well so it's
worth emphasizing who's actually ended
up in these databases so we have this
rough you know over 135,000 people
across the exomes and the genomes who
are in the nomad database these people
are not necessarily well they come
primarily from case control studies of
common of relatively common complex
adult onset diseases the big hitters in
terms of the major diseases included in
the database type 2 diabetes early onset
myocardial infarction or heart attack
and newer psychiatric conditions like
schizophrenia and bipolar so about half
the people are controls for those
studies in about half the people cases
now we have as best we can depleted this
resource of people no one to have severe
pediatric disease so the types of
Mendelian diseases that gild talked
about as well as their first degree rail
but of course some some individuals in
this in this cohort will still be ill or
will go on to become ill later on
through adult onset rare disorders
however we think that the levels of
severe disease within this population of
probably broadly comparable to the
general population as a whole so this is
a reasonable reference data set if
you're interested in figuring out if a
variant that is present in your rare
disease patient is present in the
general population and if so what
frequency it has within that population
and I won't go into detail about some of
the work we're doing here but about 40%
of the samples have some clinical data
available about in fact about 1/3 of the
samples have consent that is consistent
with recontact so for a subset of these
individuals we can actually go back if
we find interesting genotypes we can
actually go back and see what sorts of
phenotypes they have or at least get
some limited information about their
clinical status so I'm showing this
slide purely to indicate that this has
been a project that is involved in an
enormous number of data donators so
principal investigators who've allowed
their data to be used in this process I
think at last count were up to about 107
pis who signed an MoU that allows the
data to be used in this in this project
so huge thanks to them and of course to
the to our funders for making this
possible so this is one of the first
things we did across the Nomad dataset
this is a principal component analysis
basically just showing the first three
principal components which correspond
broadly speaking to geographical
ancestry across the nomad individuals
here we've generated this based on about
just over 50,000 well called single
nucleotide variants and we have inferred
the population labels using a random
forest approach with a set of about
40,000 people of so called no and
ancestry so what we can see in this plot
is that we have a pretty diverse set of
individuals have been sequenced here a
big cloud of individuals of European
ancestry we have clusters corresponding
to Finnish ancestry and Ashkenazi Jewish
big cloud up here of South Asian
individuals and we also have clusters
corresponding to individuals of Latino
ancestry African and African American as
well as East Asian East Asian ancestry
so this is by no means a comprehensive
sampling of human genetic diversity in
fact we're not even close we're missing
for instance enormous swaths of
diversity in Africa the Middle East is
missing and this is because of the
ascertainment biases have gone into
generating the samples that gone in have
gone into this dataset but what we do
have is
thousands of individuals for each of a
set of major relatively major
Continental groups and this is really
important if we want to be able to
assign relatively confidently population
frequency estimates for variants that we
find in rare disease patients from those
continents and if you're interested in
accessing the data one of the key
principles of X AK and Nomad actually
right from the very beginning was that
we wanted this to be a resource not just
for us but for anyone who wanted to look
up variants on their patients so you can
go to Nomad Bird institute.org you can
look up your favorite gene I'm sure you
guys all have a favorite gene when you
do you will find the these blue Peaks
that correspond to the coverage across
the exomes and the green line represents
the coverage across the genomes across
the exons of that particular gene below
that is a big long table of variants
that tells you every variant that we
have discovered within that gene across
both the coding and the non-coding
regions and you can click on those to
learn more about how common they are in
the population and how confident we are
that they're actually real including for
most variants actually a snapshot of the
raw read support telling us that that
variant is actually a genuine variant
and you can also download a cites VCF
that gives you a complete list of every
variant that we've called as well as its
frequency across populations and that's
available for use in any in any setting
without embargo or any restrictions
whatsoever on use so I wanted to talk
about some of the scientific things that
we can do once we have a collection of
135,000 exomes and genomes one of the
things that we spend a lot of time
thinking about is ways that we can look
at not just the variants that are
present in this dataset but also the
parents that are missing from the
dataset and I and in that in that sense
I mean informatively missing from the
dataset and so to do this we worked very
closely with Caitlin smoker a graduate
student in mark Ally's lab she had
developed a statistical model that
allowed her to predict actually with
quite high confidence given no one
mutation rates how many variants of a
particular functional class we should
expect to see in each gene in the genome
in a collection of 60,000 people or 135
thousand people and so this allows us to
say you can see in this plot here for a
setup for a variant type like a
synonymous variance for instance which
are variants that are found within
coding regions but don't change the
amino acid sequence how many how many
synonymous variants we would expect to
see in each gene that's shown here on
the x-axis under Caitlin's model each
dot here is a gene and on the y-axis we
have the number of variants that were
the number of variants of that type they
were actually observed in the 60,000
people in X ACK
and you can see that the fit for
synonymous variants is extremely good in
r-squared about 0.98 and so that tells
us that this model is actually very well
calibrated for variants that aren't
subject to strong natural selection but
that a relationship begins to break down
in fact breaks down very severely as we
start looking at variants that do
actually have a functional impact on
genes so here we're focusing on genes
that are what we call lots of function
genes that is they're predicted to break
the function of a protein coding gene
and you can see here that the
relationship here is far from linear
almost all the genes in the genome have
fewer loss of function variants than we
would expect to see by chance and it is
not surprising at all what it tells us
is that for most genes in the genome
lots of function variants are bad and so
as a result they tend to be removed from
the population by natural selection
what's cool about this though is that
with 60,000 people and even more so with
135,000 people we can actually say from
many of the genes in the genome how far
below the line does that dream fall and
therefore how strong is the action of
natural selection that's acting on loss
of function variants in that particular
gene so that really gives us a measure
about how critical that gene is and how
bad it is when you break it so just to
give you two examples this is a gene
called ink 1h1 where we know exactly
what happens when you break it
heterozygous missense and loss of
function variants in this gene result in
some pretty nasty neurodevelopmental
disorders including seizure disorders
and intellectual disability Caitlyn's
model is very well calibrated for
synonymous variants in this gene and the
gene is missing about two thirds of the
missense variants and virtually all of
the loss of function variants that we
would expect to see by chance we expect
would expect to say 161 in fact we only
see four and of those four two of them
are artifacts one is a sequencing error
one is an annotation error there are in
fact two people who appear to be
carrying lots of function variants in
this gene we don't have finished up data
about them and in fact they may actually
suffer from these disorders so that's
where we know what happens when you
break the gene this is a gene where we
don't know what happens in humans and
this gene you br5 we know is involved in
the ubiquitin pathway we know if you're
knock it out in mice that kills them
during embryogenesis but there's no no
inhuman loss of function phenotype but
it has a profile that's extremely
simulated in Quon h1 telling us actually
with very high confidence that
heterozygous lots of function mutations
in this gene do something probably
something pretty nasty probably
resulting in some kind of relatively
severe human disease phenotype the fact
that we don't know what their disease
phenotype is yet could mean one of two
things we just have in sequence the
right people yet or it could be that in
this results in embryo in embryo loss so
heterozygous loss of function results in
people dying before they can actually be
born so overall we identify more than
3000 genes with a near complete loss of
loss of function variants compared to
expectations we call these high in genes
with a high probability of loss of
function intolerance or high PLI and
that includes almost all of the known
genes we're knocking out a single copy
is enough to cause disease but
importantly more than 70% of these genes
we have no idea what they do there's no
Associated human phenotype in fact for
most of them we don't know what the
molecular function is and so we now
prioritize these genes extraordinarily
heavily when we when we start looking at
disease phenotypes and this is already
proven extremely useful in narrowing
down on genes in autism schizophrenia
and a whole range of other very nasty
pediatric diseases so the last thing I
wanted to talk about was an example of
how we can use these large cohorts to
understand the precise impact of
individual variants within a gene on
disease risk and this is work that's
been led by Eric Minich L this was a
very personal project for reasons I'll
describing it in in a minute and what
happened while our communica was an
analyst in my lab so Eric came to my lab
extremely motivated to work on a gene
called PRN P which encodes the prion
disease of the prion protein and his
motivation for this was his wife Sonya
who's shown here Sonya shown with her
mother this photo was taken at the
beginning of 2010 when Sonia's mother
was completely healthy over the course
of that year she underwent a pretty
terrifying cognitive decline went into
Frank dementia and an awfully passed
away at the end of that year so with
about a nine month period between the
onset of symptoms and and her dying at
the time that she died it was completely
unclear what had actually killed her but
on autopsy it was found that her brain
was full of accumulations of a
particular protein called prion protein
this is in some cases a genetic disease
or her prion disease prion protein gene
was sequenced she was found to carry a
mutation that was known to cause in a
dominant way very severe prion disease
called fatal familial insomnia so Sonya
had a 50% chance of actually carrying
that same mutation she then had was
faced with the choice of whether or not
she wanted to be tested herself a mother
had died in her 50s she was at the time
in her early 30s she and Eric thought
about it and then decided to go ahead
and get tested and in early 2011
Sonya learned that she too carries the
same variant that killed her mother so
as far as we know every
who carries this particular variant has
a hundred percent chance of going on to
die from prion disease there's many ways
of responding to this kind of incredibly
catastrophic information Erick and Sonia
responded in a way that I still to this
day find inspiring they quit their jobs
Eric at the time was a town planner
Sonia was a lawyer harbour trained
lawyer so they abandoned their
respective careers and retrained
completely as biomedical scientists
initially with Sonia training in the wet
lab and and Eric focusing on
bioinformatics work and that's what they
continued doing to this day is I'll show
you later
so when Eric came to my lab what he
wanted to know more than anything was an
answer to this question given that so he
carries this particular mutation how
likely is it that she will go on to get
prion disease miss turns out to be a
little bit uncertain this is a question
of what we call penetrants that is the
probability that a carrier of a
particular disease genotype will
actually go on to manifest that disease
this is known to be incomplete and
variable for many diseases and causing
mutations so in bracket one for instance
we know that women who have protein
truncating variants in this gene will go
on to a but somewhere between a sixty to
eighty percent chance of contracting
breast cancer but that has a big error
error bars associated with it and not
every woman who has a bracket one
mutation will go on to die from breast
cancer and in fact for most
disease-causing variants even ones that
are relatively well established we don't
actually have a good quantitative
estimate of what that penetrance is
that's also true for prion disease so
prion diseases we know a relatively rare
lifetime risk of about one in five
thousand 85% of the cases we have no
idea what causes them they appear to be
sporadic but as I mentioned 15 percent
of these cases are genetic and notorious
one percent of prion disease cases are
acquired and they can be acquired
through ingestion of contaminated meat
for instance as was the case for the
variant creutzfeldt-jakob disease
outbreak in the UK which is caused by
mad cow disease beef the genetic cases
are due to a set of over 60 knowand
dominant gain-of-function mutations in
the gene and what's amazing about this
disease is that we have incredibly good
surveillance data basically everyone who
is diagnosed with prion disease gets
reported to a surveillance center and
for most of those individuals the prion
disease gene the prion disease is
sequenced and so we have an almost
complete collection of genetic
information from diagnosed prion disease
cases across the Western world and so
what Eric said about doing was
collecting a set of information that
would allow us to compare the frequency
of these mutations in prion disease
cases versus controls so we
started with a set of population
controls and here we reasoned that
completely penetrant versions in
aggregate for a dominant disease should
be no more common in the population and
the disease that they caused so that
means that we can run analyses even in a
set of in a set of samples like X AK
where we don't know exactly whether
people will go on to get prion disease
but we can assume relatively confidently
that the the frequency of prion disease
causing mutations in that population
will be no higher than the actual
frequency of prion disease itself so we
collected our 60,000 x-axis owns all of
which all of whom had effectively
perfect coverage for the prion the prion
gene we're also able to work with
23andme to bring in information from
about half a million of their customers
all of whom had been genotyped for 16
reportedly disease-causing snips within
that gene and then in a series of feats
of pretty remarkable political jujitsu
Eric was able to collect over ten and a
half thousand cases of prion disease who
had had the P R and P gene sequence this
constitutes pretty much every known or
probable prion disease case that is that
has appeared in the US Europe Australia
and Japan for the last fifteen to twenty
years
it's the biggest collection of rare
disease cases that I have ever worked
with and probably the biggest collection
of cases we'll ever get for something
like prion disease so this is a really
remarkable data set to do a comparison
on and so we can calculate pretty easily
how many individuals we would expect to
see in our 60,000 x AK individuals who
actually do have real variants the goat
that will cause our prion disease and if
you multiply these slightly hand-wavy
numbers out you end up with a number
that is somewhere between one and two
individuals who carry a mutation that
will go on to kill them of prion disease
so that's the expected number the actual
observed number turns out to be much
higher so we found 16 different
mutations so sorry I think it's 12
different mutations in PRN P that a
previously we reported to be pathogenic
and 52 individuals carried them so
that's 30 times higher than what we
would expect to see given the frequency
of the disease in the population there's
multiple possible explanations here it
could be that prion disease is actually
terrifyingly more common than we think
it is we're pretty confident that's not
the case so by far the most likely
explanation is that some of these
previously reported disease-causing
mutations actually don't cause disease
in everyone or perhaps in some cases
don't cause disease in anyone they've
been falsely reported as being
pathogenic so to explore that we
generated a plot that looks like this
and as well as did a bunch of
statistical analyses that I'm not going
to go through here this plot is very
simple basically what it shows on the
x-axis is the number of times we
observed
a particular reported prion disease
causing mutation in our cases so that
basically tells us how common it is in
patients who went on to get the disease
and on the y-axis we have the frequency
of the same variance in X arc again a
population a set of population controls
broadly representative of the general
population and the variance then fall
down into three broad categories on the
X along the XS to be x axis we have
variants that are seen in cases but are
seen never or very rarely in controls
these are these alternates of these four
variants along this axis all turn out to
be variants with incredibly strong
evidence for actually being pathogenic
and disease-causing and as far as we can
tell every individual who has ever
carried these variants has indeed gone
on to die from prion disease if they
survive into their 50s and unfortunately
that does include d1 718 which is the
variant that Sony carries on the y-axis
we have a set of variants that are at
relatively low frequency in cases
they're also relatively low frequency
basically the same frequency in controls
so we have knowing there's no
information here whatsoever to indicate
that these variants are actually
associated with with prion disease and
in fact certainly for these variants the
cluster up here we can very confidently
rule them out as having any effect
whatsoever on prion disease risk at all
so these are variants that have
accidentally been associated with Rhian
disease because they happen to be an
individual who died from sporadic prion
disease and as a result they ended up in
the databases and we can now mo-mo in
most cases throw those away and then
there's a set of variants really
interesting variants in the middle who
are too common in cases to be completely
benign but also too common in controls
to be fully pathogenic and these are
variants they're clearly a product of
incomplete penetrance that is the cause
diseases and some people but not in
others we can calculate with some
confidence the actual absolute lifetime
risk of prion disease for people who
carry each of these mutations and that
ranges enormously from one in a thousand
risk for this variant up here but still
confidently above zero and down to about
ten percent risk for this for this
variant down here that has profound
implications for genetic counseling for
all three of these variants there was
information in the literature that
suggested that there was incomplete
penetrance but we had no idea what these
risk estimates actually were and now
people who are working with families
affected by these mutations can go back
and give them a relatively well
calibrated estimate of how likely it is
that another family member who carries
those mutations will go on to get the
disease just to give an example about
how this information can change lives
this is
there was an opinion piece that
accompanied the publication of this
prion disease work back early last year
and in that Robert Greene clinician at
Brigham and Women's describes a patient
that he was seeing at the time this this
patients mother had died like Sonia's
mother had died of prion disease it was
unknown what the cause was this patient
had had her prion disease prion gene
sequenced and was found to carry a
mutation called a 196 a and she had been
told as a result it was very likely she
would go to go on to die from prion
disease in 450s it turns out that e 196
a is one of the is the mutation for
which we are by far the most confident
that this has absolutely no association
with prion disease this is a completely
accidental finding this woman Robert was
able to return that data back to her he
was also able to say that looking back
through the literature there is no
information on segregation of this
variant within prion disease families
there's no family history and patients
who carry that particular variant and
the frequency is absolutely no higher in
cases than it is in controls so her
probability of going on to get prion
disease is no higher than the population
average so basically Robert was able to
commute a death sentence in the case in
this particular case and that of course
can have transformative impacts in other
ways as well so this information did not
change as far as we know Sonja's risk of
going on to get prion disease but I
think it did in many ways reestablish
Eric and Sonja's commitment to working
as hard as I can to come up with a
therapeutic approach to reducing the
levels of prion protein in Sonia's brain
to the level that it's actually possible
to ameliorate her risk of going on to
get prion disease in this case the
therapeutic target is actually extremely
clear if if it's possible to get a
chemical agent into Sonia's brain it
reduces the overall levels of native
prion protein it's almost certain that
she will be able to reduce that risk and
Eric and Sonya are now working at a lab
at the Broad Institute their PhD
students at Harvard but amazingly have
their own lab at the Broad Institute and
they're working in collaboration with a
number of industry partners to produce
compounds that will hopefully be able to
produce exactly that effect over then
over the next 10 to 15 years which is
the time that Sonya has left to come up
with such a therapy and of course we all
wish them the best in that in that quest
so we have a lot of work to do to be
able to expand no matter to be able to
answer similar questions for a whole
range of other disease genes we're very
interested in doing in continuing to
expand this we will be expanding this to
over 65,000 whole human genomes with a
new core set that will hopefully be
generated later this year calling
structural variants across the entire
and instead of analyses focused on
protein truncating variants as well as
looking at constraint in non-coding
regions and I think the key points that
that's worth emphasizing in the context
of this presentation is firstly the
naturally occurring human genetic
variation is really useful for
understanding both the impact of
variation in a disease setting but also
in terms of understanding human biology
but the more humans we have sequenced
and phenotype and the more diverse their
ancestry the better off we are in terms
of understanding this disease risk that
everyone carries rare genetic variants
it is true that most interesting
variants are rare but it's also
importantly true that most rare variants
are not actually particularly
interesting and these large-scale
reference databases help to distinguish
between those two scenarios and finally
one of the things that I think has been
a real strength of X icono matt has been
we've been very fortunate to benefit
from a human genomics community that's
been willing to share data openly and
rapidly but there's still a lot of work
that we as a community can do to make
that process better and it's really over
only with that open and rapid data
sharing that we can build resources like
this and make them available to the
world
so that'll finish by thanking everyone
who's been involved in generating this
generating and analyzing this important
resource again including the analysis
team production team abroad the
individuals who built the nomad website
and once again the genomics platform and
the Hale team for all the critical work
in building this data out thanks to you
guys for listening
[Applause]